[Music]
Isis says that it is sending 400 foreign
fighters to attack Europe this as the
chairman of the house intelligence
committee says the Isis bombers who
murdered 34 people in Brussels were
targeting Americans President Obama says
he is doing everything possible to
prevent an attack on U.S soil but our
next guest says authorities are doing
nothing here to prevent another attack
Robert Spencer is the director of jihad
watch and the author of the book The
Complete infidels guide to Isis there's
a picture of the book right there good
morning Robert thanks for joining us
thank you so what makes you believe that
this Administration is doing nothing to
prevent an attack here in the United
States
well for example in February 2015 the
Islamic State or Isis threatened to send
actually warned they were going to send
500 000 refugees into Europe they
weren't just trying to provoke a
humanitarian crisis although that's
certainly part of their agenda they were
intending and are intending to send
Jihad active Jihad terrorists among
those refugees the Lebanese education
minister in September said that there
were 25 000 active jihadis in refugee
camps on their way to Europe in his
country and many of them are there now
and then Obama wants to bring tens of
thousands of these refugees here there
is absolutely no way despite his
assurances to vet them to determine who
were jihadis and who were not Robert
we've been talking this morning about
the neighborhood in Mullen beak where
the Paris attacks what happened in
Brussels and also the train incident
from Amsterdam to Paris it all was
coordinated by gentlemen who or or men I
should say terrorists who lived in that
one neighborhood do we see anything like
that happening here in the U.S
so far we don't see those kind of no-go
zones Sharia enclaves in the United
States and it's unlikely given the
nature of the United States at this
point that they're going to develop the
problem however is that there's no
challenge being made to the underlying
ideology and it is being taught in
American mosques surveys have shown four
separate and independent surveys since
1998 have shown that 80 percent of
mosques in the United States teach
hatred of Jews and Christians and the
necessity ultimately to replace the
Constitution with Islamic law so
nothing's being done to challenge the
Muslims in those mosques to Institute
programs to reject the teachings that
Isis represents that Al Qaeda represents
if that doesn't change then we're just
heading for disaster so are you saying
it's just a matter of time
yes it's not a matter of if but of when
Wow Let's put up a map this is a James
Comey the um head of the FBI has said
the FBI director has said that Isis
investigations are going on in all 50
states look at this map I mean the
numbers staggering when you look at that
map it really hits home for us what do
you make of this what do we do well ice
well we have to we have to stop bringing
in these migrants we have to challenge
the mosques and the Islamic communities
in the United States to do something to
back up their palate and pro forma
condemnations of Isis with real action
and to show in an honest way that they
are trying to combat this ideology uh
this wouldn't be spreading so much if it
weren't mainstream all right so you do
say challenge the mosques all right
Robert Spencer thank you the author of
the complete infidel's guide to Isis
thanks for being with us this morning
thank you